The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HAIM SOMPOLINSKY:
My topic today is
discussing sensory
representations
in deep cortex-like
architectures.
I should say the
topic is perhaps
toward a theory of
sensory representations
in deep networks.
As you will see, our
attempt is to develop
a systematic theoretical
understanding of the capacity
and limitations of
architectures of that type.
The general context
is well known.
In many sensory systems,
we see information
is propagating from the
periphery, like the retina,
to primary visual cortex, and
then, of course, many stages up
to a very high level, or maybe
the hippocampal structure.
It's not purely feedforward.
There are backward, massive
backward or top-down
connections, the
recurrent connections,
and some of those extra
features I'll talk about.
But the most intuitive
feature of that
is simply a transformation
or filtering
of data across multiple stages.
Similarly in auditory pathway.
In other systems, we see a
similar structure or aspect
of similar structure as well.
A well-known and a
classical formative system
for computational
science is cerebellum,
where you have information
coming from the mossy fiber
layer, then expand enormously
into a granule layer,
and then converge
to a Purkinje cell.
So if you look at
a single Purkinje
cell, the output of the
cerebellum, as a unit,
then you see there is,
first, an expansion
from 1,000 to two
orders of magnitude
higher in the granule layer.
And then convergence of
200,000 or so parallel fibers
onto a single Purkinje cell.
And there are, those type
of modules, many, many
across the cerebellum.
So, again, a transformation
which involves, in this case,
expansion and then convergence.
In the basal ganglia, which
I wouldn't categorize it
as a sensory system.
More related to motor.
Nevertheless, you see
cortex converging first
to various stages of
the basal ganglia,
and then expanding
again to cortex.
Hippocampus has also multiple
pathways, but some of them
include a convergence.
For instance, convergence
to a CA3, and then expansion
again to cortex.
But there are other
multiple pathways as well,
different stages of sensory
information propagating,
of course, across them.
And, finally, the
artificial network story
of deep neural networks,
all of you may have heard.
Input layer, then
sequence of stages.
Purely feedforward.
And at least the
canonical leading network
is one that the output layer
has object recognition, object
classification task.
And the whole network
is studied by backprop,
supervised learning for that.
What I'll talk about is more
in the spirit of the idea
that the first stages
are more general purpose
than the specific classic
task in the output layer.
So there are many issues.
Number of stages that are
required, the size of them,
why compression or expansion.
In many systems, you'll see that
the fraction of active neurons
is small in the expanded layer.
That's what we call sparseness.
So high sparseness
means small number
of neurons active at
any given stimulus.
It's just the terminology
is somewhat confusing.
So high sparseness is small
number of active neurons.
One important and crucial
question is how to transform.
What are the
filters, the weights
that are good for transforming
sensory information from one
layer to another?
And, in particular,
whether random weights
is good enough, or maybe
even optimal in some sense.
Or one needs more
structure, the more
learned type of synaptic way.
This is a crucial question,
perhaps not for machine
learning but for computational
neuroscience, because there
is some experimental
evidence, for at least
of some of the systems
that are studied,
that the mapping from
the compressed, original
representation to the
sparse representation
is actually done by
randomly connected weights.
So one example is
olfactory cortex.
The mapping of
olfactory representation
from the olfactory bulb,
so from glomerulus layer,
to the piriform cortex
seems to be random,
as far as one can say.
Similarly, in the
cerebellum, the example
that I mentioned
before, when one
looks at the mapping
from the mossy fiber
to the granule cell,
again enormous expansion
by a few orders of magnitude.
Nevertheless, they
seem to be random.
Now, of course, one cannot
say exclusively that they are
random and there are no subtle
correlations or structures.
But, nevertheless, there
is a strong motivation
to ask whether random
projections are good enough.
And if not, what does
it mean structured?
What kind of structure is
appropriate for this task?
Question of top-down
and feedback loops,
recurrent connections,
and so on.
So that's all I hope to,
at least briefly, mention
later on in my talk.
So before I continue, most of,
or a large part of the talk
will be based on published
and unpublished work
with Baktash Babadi,
who was, until recently,
a postdoctoral, a Swartz
Fellow at Harvard University.
Went to practice medicine.
Elia Frankin, a master student
at the Hebrew University.
SueYeon, who all you
know here, at Harvard.
Uri Cohen, a PhD student
at the Hebrew University.
And Dan Lee from
Penn University.
So here is our formalization
of the problem.
We have an input
layer, denoted 0.
Typically, it's a small,
it's a compressed layer
with dense representation.
So here, every input
will generate maybe half
of the population, on average,
Then there is a
feedforward layer
of synaptic weights,
which expand
to a higher-dimension layer,
which we call cortical layer.
It's expanded in terms
of the number of neurons.
So this will be S1.
It is sparse because the
f, the fraction of neurons
that are active for each given
input vector, will be small.
So it is expanded and sparse.
That will be the first part
of my talk, discussing this.
Then, later on, I'll talk
about staging, cascading
this transformation
to several stages.
And ultimately
there is a readout,
will be some
classification task.
1 will be one classification.
2 will be another
classification rule, et cetera,
each one of them
with synaptic weights
which are learned to
perform that task.
So we call that a
supervised layer, and that's
the unsupervised layer.
So that's a formalization
of the problem.
And, as you will see, we'll
make enormously simplifying
abstraction of the
real biological system
in order to try to
gain some insight
about the computational
capacity of such systems.
So the first
important question is
what is the statistics,
the statistical structure
of the input?
So the input is kind of
n-dimensional vector,
where n, or n0, when n is
the number of units here.
So each sensory event evokes
a pattern of activity here.
But what is the structure,
the statistical structure,
that we are working with?
And the simplest one that
we are going to discuss
is the following.
So we assume, basically,
that the inputs
are coming from a
mixture of, so to speak,
a mixture of
Gaussian statistics.
It's not going to be Gaussian
because, for simplicity, we'll
assume they are binary.
But this doesn't
matter actually.
So imagine that this is kind
of a graphical represent--
a caricature of
high-dimensional space.
And imagine the inputs,
the sensory inputs,
imagine that they are clustered
around templates or cluster
centers.
So these will be the
centers of these balls.
And the input itself is
coming from the neighborhoods
of those templates.
So each input will be
one point in this space,
and it will be originating from
one of those ensembles of one
of those states.
So that's a simple architecture.
And we are going--
in real space, it
will be mapping
from one of those states
into another state
in the next layer.
And then, finally, the
task will be to take--
imagine that some of those
balls are classified as plus.
Let's say the olfactory factory
stimuli, and some of them
are classified as appetitive,
some of them as aversive.
So the output layer,
the readout unit,
has to classify some of
those spheres as a plus,
and some of them are minus.
And, of course,
depending on how many of
them are in a dimensionality,
and their location,
this may or may not
be an easy problem.
So, for instance,
here it's fine.
There is-- a linear classifier
on the input space can do it.
Here, I think there are, there
should be some mistakes here.
Yeah, here.
So here is a case where the
linear classifier at the input
layer cannot do it.
And that's our--
that's a theme which
is very popular, both in
computation neural science
and system neural science
studies in machine learning.
And the following
question comes up.
Suppose we see that there
is a transformation of data
from, let's say, a photoreceptor
layer in vision to the ganglion
cells at the output
of the retina,
then to cortex in
several stages.
How do we gauge,
how do we assess
what is the advantage for the
brain to transform information
from one, let's say, from retina
to V1, and so on and so forth.
After all, in this
feedforward's architecture,
no net information is
generated at the next layer.
So if no net information
is generated,
the question is, what did we
gain by these transformations?
And one possible answer is that
it is reformatted, reformatting
the sensory representation into
different representation which
will make subsequent
computations simpler.
So what does it mean, subsequent
computation is simpler?
One notion of simplicity is
whether subsequent computation
can be realized by a
simple linear readout.
So that's the strategy that
we are going to adopt here.
And this is to ask,
as the information,
as the representation
is changing
as you go from one
layer to another,
how well a linear readout will
be able to perform the task.
So that's the input.
That's the story.
And then, as I said,
there is an input,
unsupervised representations,
and supervised at the end.
I need to introduce notations.
Bear with me.
This is a computational talk.
I cannot just talk about ideas,
because the whole thing is
to be able to actually come up
with a quantitative theory that
tests ideas.
So let me introduce notations.
So at the centers,
at each layer,
you can ask what is the
representation of the centers
of these stimuli?
And I'll denote the
center by a bar.
And mu is index of the patterns.
So mu goes from 1 to P. P Is
the number of those balls,
number of those spheres, or
number of those clusters,
if you think about
clustering some sensory data.
So P would be the
number of clusters.
i, from 1 to N, is simply the
neuron or the unit activation
at each mu.
And L is the layer.
So 0 is the input layer.
It's up to L layer.
So this would be 0, 1.
The mean activation
at each layer from 1
on will just have
to be a constant
to be f. f goes from 0 to 1.
The smaller f is, the sparser
the representation is.
We will assume that the input
representation is dense.
So this is 0.5.
N, again, we'll assume
to be, for simplicity,
a constant across layers, except
for the first layer, where
there is expansion.
You can vary those parameters,
and actually the theory
accommodates
variations of those.
But that's the
simplest architecture.
You expend a dense
representation
into a sparse higher
dimension, and you
keep doing it as you go along.
So that's notation.
Now, how do we assess what
is the next stages doing
to those clusters.
So, as I said, one measure
is take a linear classifier
and see how linear
classifier performs.
But, actually, you can
also look at the statistics
of the injected sensory
stimuli at each layer
and learn something from it.
And, basically, I'm
going to suggest
looking at two major
statistical aspects
of the data in each layer
of the transformation.
One of them is noise, and
one of them is correlation.
So what is noise?
So, again, noise will be
simply the radius, or measure
of the radius of the sphere.
So if you had only the
templates as inputs,
the problem would be simple.
Problem would be easy as long
as we have enough dimension.
You expand it.
You can easily do
linear classifier
and solve the problem.
So the problem, in
our case, is the fact
that the input is actually
the infinite number of inputs,
or exponentially large
number of possible inputs,
because they all come from a
Gaussian or a binarized version
of a Gaussian noise
around the templates.
And I'll denote
the noise by delta.
0 means no noise.
The normalization is such that
1 means that they are random.
So delta equals to 1 means that,
basically, you cannot tell,
the input, whether it's coming
from here or from any other
points in the input space.
The other thing,
correlations, is more subtle.
So I'm going to assume
that those balls are
coming from kind of
uniform distribution.
Imagine you take
a template here.
You draw a ball around it.
You take a template.
Here, you draw a ball.
Everything is kind of
uniformly distributed.
The only structure
is the fact that data
comes from this
mixture of Gaussians
or noisy patterns
around those centers.
So that's fine.
But as you project those
clusters into the next stage,
I claim that those
centers, those templates,
get new representation, which
can actually have structure
in them, simply by the fact
that you put all of them
into this common synaptic
weights into the next layer.
And I'm going to measure this
by Q. And, basically, low Q or 0
Q is basically a kind of
randomly uniformly distributed
centers.
And I'll always start from
that at the input layer.
But then there is
a danger, or it
might happen that,
as you propagate
this information or
this representation
through the next layer, the
centers will look like that,
or the data, structure of
the data, looks like that.
So, on average, the distance
between two centers,
on average, is the same as here.
But they are clumped together.
It's kind of random
clustering of the clusters.
And that can be
induced by the fact
that the data is feedforwarded
from this representation.
That can pose a problem.
If there is no noise, then
there is, again, no problem.
You can differentiate
between them, and so on.
But if there is noise, this
can aggravate the situation,
because some of the clusters
become dangerously close
to each other.
And we will come to it.
But, anyway, so we have
this delta, the noise,
the size of the clusters, and
we have Q, the correlations,
how they are clumped
in each representation.
And now we can ask
how delta evolve
when you go from
one presentation
to another, how Q evolve from
one presentation to another,
and how linear classifier
performance will
change from one
representation to another.
So the simplicity
of this assumption
allows for a kind of systematic,
analytical exploration or study
of this.
These are definitions.
Let's go on.
So what will be the
ideal situation?
So the ideal situation
will be that I
start from some level
of noise, which is
my spheres at the input layer.
I may or may not start
with some correlation.
The simplest case would be
that I start from randomly
distributed centers.
So this would be 0.
And the best situation
will be that,
as I propagate the sensory
stimuli, delta, the noise,
will go to 0.
As I said, if the
noise goes to 0,
you are left with
basically points.
And those points, if there
is enough dimensionality,
those points would be
easily classifiable.
It would also be
good, if the noise
doesn't go to 0, to have
also kind of uniformly spread
clusters.
So it will be good to
keep Q to be small.
So let's look at one layer.
So let's look at this.
We have the input layer,
the output layer here,
and the readout.
The first question is what to
choose for this input layer.
So the simplest answer
would be choose random.
So what we do, we
just take Gaussian.
The Gaussian weights in
this layer are very simple.
0 mean, with some normalization.
It doesn't matter.
Then we project them into
each one of these guys here.
And then we add threshold
to enforce the sparsity
that we want.
So whatever the activation here
is, whatever the input here is,
the threshold makes
sure that only
the f with the largest
input will be active,
and the rest will be 0.
So there is a nonlinearity,
which is of course extremely
important.
If you map one layer to another
with a linear transformation,
you don't gain anything in
terms of classification.
So there is a nonlinearity,
simply a threshold nonlinearity
after an input projection.
All right.
So how we are going to do this?
So it's straightforward to
actually compute analytically
what will happen to a noise.
So imagine you take two input
vectors with some Hamming
distance apart from each other.
You map them by convolving
them, so to speak,
with Gaussian weights,
and then thresholding
them to get some sparsity.
So f is the sparsity.
The smaller the f is,
the sparser it is.
So this is the noise level,
the normalized Gaussian--
I'm sorry-- sphere radius
or Hamming distance
in the output layer, and
also the input layer.
Well if 0 at start, then of
course you start at the origin.
If you are random at the input,
you will be random there.
So these points are fine.
But, as you see,
immediately there
is an amplification of the
noise as you go from the input
to the output.
So you start from 0.2, but you
get actually, after one layer,
to 0.6.
And, actually, the
sparser it is--
so this is a relatively
high sparsity,
or at least you go from here
to here by increasing sparsity,
namely f becomes smaller.
And as f becomes
smaller, this curve
is actually steeper and steeper.
So not only you
amplify noise, but you
also-- the amplification
becomes worse the sparser
the representation is.
So that is the kind
of negative result.
The idea that you can gain
by expanding data to a higher
dimension and make
them more separable
later on dates back to David
Marr's classical theory
of the cerebellum.
But what we show here is
that, if you think not about
clean data, a set of points
that you want to separate,
but you think about the
more realistic case of you
have noisy data, or
data with high variance,
then the situation
is very different.
So a random expansion
actually amplifies those.
And that's a theme that will--
actually, we will live
with it as we go along.
Random expansion is doing the
separation of the templates.
But the problem is it also
separates two nearby points
within a cluster.
It also separates them.
So everything becomes
separated from each other.
And this is why
noise is amplified.
Now, what about the most subtle
thing, which is the kind of
overlap between the centers?
So, on average, the centers are
as far apart as random things.
But if you look, not
on average, but you
look at the
individual pairs, you
see that there is an
excess correlations
or overlap between them.
So this is overlap
between the centers.
Again, on average, it is 0,
but the variance is not 0.
On average it's like
random, but the variance
is different, is
larger than random.
And there is an amplification.
There is a generation
of this excess overlap,
although it's nicely
controlled by sparsity.
So as sparsity goes down,
these correlations go down.
So that's not a
tremendous problem.
The major problem, as
I said, is the noise.
By the way, you can nicely do
an exercise where you generate,
you look at this cortical
layer representation,
and you do SVM, or
PCA, and you look
at the eigenvalue spectrum.
So if you just look at random
sparse points, and you look
at the SVD this is the
eigenvalues number ranked--
then that's what you find.
It's the famous
Marchenko-Pastur distribution.
But, in our case, you see
there is an extra power.
In this case, the
input layer is 100,
so the extra power
in the input layer,
in the first input eigenvalue.
Now, why is it so?
What Q is telling
us, what nonzero Q
is telling us is the following.
You take a set of random
points, and you project them
into higher dimensions.
You start with 100 dimensions,
and you project them
in 1,000 dimensions.
On average, they are random.
But actually-- so
you would imagine
that it's a perfect thing.
You project them
with random weights.
Then you would
imagine that you just
created a set of random points
in the expanded dimension
representation.
If this was so, then
if you do SVM or PCA
on this representation,
you will find
what you expect from a PCA
of a set of random points.
And this is this one.
In fact, there is a trace of
low dimensionality in the data.
So I think that's an
important point, which
I would like to explain.
You start from a set of points.
If you don't threshold
them and you just map them
into 1,000-dimensional space,
those 100-dimensional input
will remain 100-dimensional.
Just be rotated, and
so on, but everything
will live in
100-dimensional space.
Now you add thresholding,
high thresholding by sparsity.
So those 100-dimensional
subspace becomes now
1,000-dimensional sparsity
because of the nonlinearity.
But this nonlinearity, although
it takes 100-dimensional input
and makes them
1,000-dimensional,
it's still not like random.
This 1,000-dimensional
cloud is still elongated.
It's not simply
uniformly distributed.
And this is the signature
that you see here.
In the first largest
100 eigenvalues,
there is extra power
relative to the random.
The rest is not 0.
So if you look here,
this goes up to 1,000.
The rest is not 0.
So the system is,
strictly speaking,
1,000-dimensional space,
but it's not random.
It has increased
power in 100 channels.
If you do a readout,
a linear classifier
readout, what you find in this--
again, when you expand
with random weights,
you find that there is
an optimal sparsity.
So this is the readout error.
For a classifier, the
output is a function
of the sparsity for
different levels of noise.
And you see that, in the
case of random weights,
there is a very high
sparsity, is bad.
There Is an optimal
sparsity or sparseness,
and then there is
a shallow increase
in the error when you go
to a denser representation.
One important point
which I want to emphasize
coming from the analysis--
let me skip equations--
and this is what you see here.
The question is, can I do better
by further increase the layer?
So here I plot the readout
error as a function
of the size of cortical layer.
Can I do better?
If I make the kernel
dimensionality infinite,
can I do better?
Well, it can do better if
you start with 0 noise.
But if you have noisy
inputs, then basically,
the performance saturates.
And that's kind of surprising.
We were expecting
that, if you go
to a larger and larger
representation, eventually
the error will go to 0.
But it doesn't go to 0.
And that actually
happens even for what we
call structured representation.
And that's the same for
different types of readout--
perceptual, and
pseudo-inverse, SVM.
All of them show this
saturation as you increase
the size of cortical layer.
And that's one of the very
important outcome of our study.
That when you talk
about noisy inputs,
you can think about it as kind
of more generalization task.
Then there is a limit
about what you gain
by expanding representation.
Even if you expand in a
nonlinear fashion and you
increase the dimensionality,
you cannot combat the noise,
at least up to some level.
Beyond some level, there is
no point of further expansion,
because basically
the error saturates
Let me, since time
goes fast, let
me talk about the alternatives.
So if random weights
are not doing so well,
what are the alternatives?
The alternative is to do some
kind of unsupervised learning.
Here we are doing it
in a kind of a shortcut
of unsupervised learning.
What is the shortcut?
We say the following.
Imagine that these
layers, the learner
knows about the representation
of the clusters.
It doesn't know the labels.
In other words, whether
those are pluses and those
are minuses, which one
are pluses and minuses.
But he does know about
the statistical structure
of the input, and
this is this S bar.
These are the centers.
So we want to encode the
statistical structure
of these input in this
expansion of the weights.
And the way we do the simplest
way is the kind of Hebb rule.
We do the following.
We say let's first choose, or
recruit, or allocate a state,
a sparse state here, randomly
chosen, to associate,
to represent each
one of the clusters.
So these are the R. R are the
randomly chosen patterns here.
And then we associate
between those randomly chosen
representations and
the actual centers
of the clusters of the inputs.
So this is S bar and R. And
then we do the association
by the simple, what's
called Hebb rule.
So this Hebbian rule
associates cluster
center with a randomly
assigned state
in the cortical layer in
a kind of simple summation
or outer product
for the Hebb rule.
There are more
sophisticated ways to do it,
but that's the simplest
one of doing it.
So it turns out that this simple
rule has enormous potential
for suppressing noise.
So, again, this is the input
noise and the output noise.
The Hamming distance of
the input and the output
properly normalized.
And you see that, as you go to
higher and higher sparseness,
to lower and lower
f, this is basically
the input noise is completely
quenched when f is large.
When f is 0.01, for instance,
this is this already.
Sub-linear when f 0.05 is
here, and so and so forth.
So sparse representation,
in particular,
are very effective
in suppressing noise,
but provided the inputs have
kind of unsupervised learning
encoded into them
which embed into them
the cluster structure
of the inputs.
The same or similar
thing is true for Q
for these correlations.
If you look at the-- this
was a random correlation.
This is a function of f, and
this is Q, the correlation.
It's extremely suppressed
for sparse representation.
Basically, it's
exponentially small with 1/f,
so it's basically 0 for
sparse representation.
Which means that those
centers look like randomly
distributed, essentially,
and with very small noise.
So you took these
spheres and you basically
map them into random points
with a very small radius.
So it's not surprising
that, in this case,
the error for small f-- the
error, even for large noise
values, the error is
basically small, 0.
Nevertheless, it
is still saturating
as a function of the network
size, of the cortical size.
So the saturation of performance
as a function of cortical size
is a general property
of such systems.
Nevertheless, the performance
itself for any given size
is extremely impressive, I would
say, when the system is sparse
and the noise level
is kind of moderate.
OK, let me skip this
because I don't have time.
Let me briefly talk about
extension of this story
to multi-layer.
So we are now briefly
discussing what
happens if you take this story
and you just propagate it
as you go along
the architecture.
So let's start with
random weights.
So the idea is maybe
something is good happening.
Although initially
performance was poor,
maybe we can improve
the performance
by cascading such layers.
And the answer is no,
particularly the noise level.
This is now the
number of layers.
What we discussed
before is here.
And you see the problem
becomes worse and worse.
As you continue to
propagate those signals,
the noise is amplified
and essentially goes to 1.
So basically you will get
just random performance
if you keep doing it
with random weights.
The reason-- where is it?
I missed a slide.
The reason is,
basically, that if you
think about the mapping
from one layer of noise
to another layer of noise, there
are two fixed points, 0 and 1.
The 0 fixed point is unstable.
Everything goes eventually to 1.
So it is a nice--
this system gives you
a nice perspective
about this deep network
by thinking about it
as a kind of dynamical system.
For instance, what
is the level of noise
at one layer, how it's
related to the level of noise
at previous layer.
So it's kind of iterative map.
Delta n versus delta n minus 1.
And what's good about it
is, once you kind of draw
this curve, one layer is
mapped to another layer,
you can know what happens
to a deep network.
We could just iterate this.
You have to find what
are the fixed points,
and which one is stable
and which one is not.
In this case, the 1 is
stable, the 0 is unstable.
So, unfortunately,
from any level of noise
that you will start,
you eventually go to 1.
Correlations, is a
similar story, but--
and the error will go to 0.5.
So that's very well.
There are cases, by the way,
that you can find parameters
where initially you
improve, like here.
But then eventually
it will go to 0.5.
Now, if we do similar--
if we compare this
to what happened
to the structured
weights if you keep
doing the same kind of
unsupervised Hebbian
learning from one
layer to another--
and I'll skip the details--
you see the opposite.
So here are parameter
value in which
one stage of the expansion
stage is actually
increasing the noise.
And this is because f is not too
small, and the load is large,
and the noise is starting.
So you can have such situation.
But even in such situation,
eventually the system
goes into stages where the
noise basically goes to 0.
And if you compare
the story why it
is so to kind of
iterative map picture,
you see that the picture
is very different.
You have one fixed point at 0.
You have one fixed point at 1.
You have intermediate
fixed point at high value.
But this is an unstable
fixed point, and both of them
are stable fixed points.
So if you start from even
from large values of noise,
eventually you
will iterate to 0.
So it does buy
you to actually go
into several stages of this
deep network to make sure
that the noise is
suppressed to 0.
Similarly for the correlations.
Even if the parameters are such
that initially correlations
are increased, and you can
find parameters like that,
eventually correlations
will go to almost 0.
And this is comparison
of the readout error
as a function of the layers
with structured weights,
and I compare it with
the readout error
of infinitely wide
layer, kind of a kernel
with infinitely wide kernel.
And you can see
that, at least for--
here I compare the same type of
unsupervised learning but two
different architectures.
One is deep network
architecture,
and the another one is shallow
architecture, infinitely wide.
I'm not claiming that we can
show that there is no kernel
or shallow architecture
which will do better,
but I'm saying if we compare
the same learning rule
but with the two
different architectures,
you'll find that
you do gain by going
into multiple stages
of nonlinearity
than by using an
infinitely wide layer.
I'll skip this.
I want to go briefly
to two more issues.
One issue is the
recurrent networks.
Why recurrent networks?
The primary reason
is that, in each one
of those stages that I refer
to, if you look at the biology,
on most of them--
not all of them but most
of them, and definitely
in neocortex--
you find massive recurrent
or lateral interactions
between each one of the layers.
So, again, we would
like to ask, what
is the computational advantage
of having this recurrent layer.
Now, in our case, we had an
extra motivation, and this is--
remember that I started in
saying that, in some cases,
there is experimental evidence
that the initial projection is
random.
So that we ask ourselves,
what happens if we do this.
If we start from
random projection,
feedforward projection, and
then add recurrent connections.
Think about it as from the
olfactory bulb, for instance,
to piriform cortex, perhaps
random feedforward projections.
But then the association,
recurrent connections
in piriform cortex
are structured.
How do we do that?
We start, we imagine starting
from random projection,
generating initial
representation
by the random projection,
and then stabilizing
those representation
into attractors
by the recurrent connections.
And that actually
works pretty well.
It's not the optimal
architecture,
but it's pretty well.
For instance, noise,
which is initially
increased by the
random projections,
were quenched by
convergence to attractors.
And, similarly, Q
will not go to 0,
but will not continue
growing, but will
go to an intermediate layer.
And the error is pretty well.
So if you look at in this
case, the error really
goes down to very low values.
But now it's not layers.
Now it is the
number of iterations
of the recurrent connections.
So you start from just input
layer, or random projection,
and then you iterate the
dynamics and it goes to 0.
So it's not the layers.
It's just the dynamics of
the convergence to attractor.
My final point.
I have 3 or 4 minutes?
OK.
My final point before wrapping
up is the question of top-down.
So recurrent, we
briefly talked about it.
But incorporating contextual
knowledge is a major question.
How can you improve
on deep networks
by incorporating, not simply
the feedforward sensory input,
but other sources of knowledge
about this particular stimulus?
And it's important that we are
not talking about knowledge
about the statistics
of the input which
can be incorporated
into the learning
of the feedforward one.
But we're talking
about inputs which are,
or knowledge, which we have now
on the network which already
has learned whatever
it has learned.
So we have a mature network,
whatever the architecture is.
We have a sensory input.
It goes feedforward.
And now we have additional
information, about
context for instance,
that we want
to incorporate with
the sensory input
to improve the performance.
So how do we do that?
It turns out to be non-trivial
computational problem.
It is very straightforward to
do it in Bayesian framework,
where you simply
update the prior
of what the sensory input is
by this contextual information.
But if you want to
implement it in the network,
you find that it's
not easy to find
the appropriate architecture.
So I'll just briefly
talk about how we do it.
So imagine you have, again,
these sensory inputs,
but now there is some
context, different contexts.
And imagine you
have an information
that the input is coming from
that particular part of state
space.
So basically the question is
how to amplify selectively
a specific set of states in
a distributed representation.
So usually when we talk
about attention, or gating,
or questions like that,
we think about, OK, we
have these neurons.
We suppress those, or
maybe amplify other ones.
Or we have a set of
axons, or pathways.
We suppress those,
and amplify those.
But what about a
representation which is more
distributed where you have
to really suppress states
rather than neural populations.
So I just won't go-- again,
it's a complicated architecture.
But, basically, we're using some
sort of a mixed representation,
where we take the sensory
input and the category
or contextual input,
mix the nonlinearity,
use them to clean it,
and propagate this.
So it's a more
complicated architecture,
but it works beautifully.
Let me show you here an
example, and you'll have
a flavor of what we are doing.
So now the input, we have
those 900 spheres or templates,
but they are organized
into 30 categories,
and 30 tokens per category.
Now, the tokens, which are
the actual sensory inputs,
are represented by,
let's say, 200 neurons.
And you have a small
number of neurons
representing a category.
Maybe 20 is enough.
So that's important,
and you don't
have to really
expand dramatically
the representation.
So this is the input.
And now we have
very noisy inputs.
If you look at the readout,
this is layers here,
and there is readout error.
If you do it on the input
layer, or any subsequent layer
here, but without
top-down information.
With structured interactions
and all that I told you,
this is such a noisy input where
the performance is basically
0.5.
There is nothing that you can
do without top-down information
in this network.
You can ask what will
be the performance.
If you have an ideal observer
that looks at the noisy input
and makes maximum
likelihood categorization.
Well, then it will
do much better.
Also not 0, so this
is at this level.
This higher error is
in virtue of the fact
that this network
is still not doing
what an optimal maximum
likelihood observer will do.
So this is the network.
This is a maximum likelihood
readout, both of them
without extra
top-down information.
And in the network that
I kind of hinted about,
if you add this top-down
information by generating
mixed representation, you get
a performance which is really
dramatically improved.
And as you keep doing it
one layer from another,
you really get a very
nice performance.
So let me just summarize.
There is one more
before summarizing.
Yeah, OK.
Before that.
OK.
So two points to bear in mind.
One of them is that what
I discussed to you today
relies on assuming either
random, comparing random
projection, to unsupervised
learning of a very simple type,
of a kind of Hebbian type.
The output can be Hebbian, or
perceptron, or SVM, and so on.
You could ask,
what happens if you
use learning rules, more
sophisticated learning rules
for the unsupervised weights?
Some of them we've studied.
But, anyway, that's something
which is important to explore.
And another very important
issue for thinking
about object
recognition in vision
and in other real-life
problem is input statistics.
Because what we assumed
is a very simple mixture
of Gaussian model.
So you can think about
the task of the network
is to take the invariance,
which is the variation away
from the center of the
spherical variation,
and to generate representation
which is invariant to that.
But this is a very simple
invariance problem,
because the
invariance was simply
restricted to these simple
geometric structures.
More problems which are closer
to what real-life problems are
will have inputs which
are, essentially, have
some structure,
but the structure
can be of a variety of shapes.
Each one of them correspond
to an object, or a cluster,
or a manifold representing an
entity, a perceptual entity.
But how you go from this
nice, simple problem
of this spherical invariance
problem to those problems,
it's of course a
challenging problem.
And that's the work which we
are now, ongoing work, also
with SueYeon Chung and Dan Lee.
But it's a story which is still
at the stage of unfolding.